afghanistan is in the grip of a
humanitarian disaster and in the midst
of a famine the crisis has been made
worse by sub-zero temperatures in recent
weeks according to the u.n 23 million
people more than half of afghanistan's
population are threatened by hunger this
winter and in urgent need of assistance
some food aid has started arriving in
kabul but much international aid was cut
when the taliban took power last august
scarcity of food means many children are
now malnourished and children's medical
wards are filling up this next report is
from the indira gandhi hospital in kabul
for weeks hardia had nothing to eat
her mother could no longer breastfeed
her and the family couldn't afford to
buy milk
14 days ago they brought her to this
hospital in kabul
she was much worse before
here she's fed milk every hour and she
can keep it down
the family situation has severely
deteriorated in the past few months
oh i
have skyrocketed i have three sons and a
daughter we were able to buy food but
recent developments have hit us
massively especially the devaluation of
the currency and inflation i'm a widow
and live in someone else's apartment
nurse sakina yusufi would normally look
after five patients
now she has over twenty
the number of people currently seeking
hospital treatment far outstrips
capacity
it was
more space
more staff and other resources for the
many patients
recently the international red cross has
been supporting the hospital with
financial aid and medicines
satara comes from a suburb of kabul and
brought her son to the children's ward
[Music]
my husband is a teacher he's not been
paid for the last three or four months
i sold a ring so i could bring my son
here for treatment
the family can only afford tea and bread
to eat often there's not enough money
for gas for heating or cooking
they say my husband will receive his
salary but i don't know if that will
happen
last week they announced they would pay
and they still haven't
sotara has the equivalent of just under
20 euros left from the sale of her ring
she doesn't know how she'll get by after
that
[Music]
we can only keep the children here for a
maximum of two months
we can't keep them any longer because we
have to make room for other children
people come to us from all over the
country
the children only go home once they're
well enough but often they're back
within a few months when their parents
have no more food left to give them
world food program executive director
david beasley has been working in
afghanistan to distribute aid dw's julia
saldelli had a chance to speak to him
here in berlin about his work
mr beasley could you give us a picture
of the humanitarian emergency unfolding
right now in afghanistan
afghanistan was already one of the
poorest countries in the world with 20
years at least of conflict with the
taliban
and now
what we're facing is catastrophic the
number of people that literally are
knocking on starvation's door is 23
million people
out of 40 million people it is horrific
in fact
i've been there several times i've been
meeting with families mothers and
fathers in fact one mother was telling
me how she had to sell her daughter to
get food
for her family in the hopes that her
daughter could be well fed by another
family and so mothers and families are
having to choose
because they have no money
do if they do have any money do i buy
a cooking oil to feed my children
or do i buy heating oil to
keep my children from freezing to death
this
is how horrific it is in afghanistan
right now
what kind of difficulties are you
encountering in delivering food to the
people in need there we've been
operating
in afghanistan before the taliban took
over and and quite frankly
it's been quite remarkable the access
that we have the taliban i have met with
our teams have met with out in the
provinces as well as in kabul and they
have assured us allowing us to operate
impartially independently neutrally and
they've honored that we've been able to
operate do what we need to do to reach
the innocent victims of this conflict if
we get the money that we need and that's
our biggest limitation right now we can
reach the afghan people without anyone
including the taliban interfering with
our operations and that's extremely
important for us but it's a humanitarian
effort enough sanctions and asset
freezes have been applied to the taliban
since they came into government and
they're hitting the economy in
afghanistan hard should these measures
be reconsidered so the long-term
solution is not humanitarian aid the
long-term solution is going to be the
international community figuring a path
forward
so that afghanistan can revitalize this
economy and move on with its life
because we've got so many crises right
now around the world because if we don't
have enough
money worldwide
where am i going to get the money to
feed all the children in afghanistan am
i going to take it from the children in
syria the children in
ethiopia the children in niger or mali
so this is a very serious issue and the
leaders around the world have got to
really sit down and find a pragmatic way
forward otherwise it's going to be
catastrophic as you've said there's
urgent need for funding not only for
afghanistan but also for other
emergencies around the world like yemen
and syria you have many times appealed
to the leaders and the millionaires of
the world for funding what has the
response been so far during this covet
experience the world's billionaires have
made unprecedented money over 5.2
billion dollars of net worth increase
per day
all we need is one day's worth of their
net worth increase to really address our
short-term crisis is that too much to
ask i don't think so because the world
needs the world's billionaires who
profited during covet to help the
world's poor david beasley executive
director of the world food program thank
you
thank you
you